I'll actually take what's happened to me
to my grave to victims of contaminated
blood among thousands at the start of a
day they thought might never come
Michele was infected with hepatitis C by
a blood transfusion given during
childbirth
she was only diagnosed three years ago
twenty-eight years that I had been
infected with hepatitis C I actually
thought I was going to die body's been
even Bailey did with it with an entity
that I didn't ask for you know I didn't
I didn't commit a crime
so don't put me on don't give me a
deficit and it's for something I've not
done wrong all I wanted was a baby and a
family Toni was a child when he lost his
dad and both his uncle's to HIV
contracted during treatment for
haemophilia I think today is going to be
very difficult I think today I'm going
to be that twelve-year-old child again
yeah if it's gonna be extremely
difficult but I'm really happy that
we're moving forward with it and the way
now the tasks the task is going to be
dealt with the infected blood scandal is
the story of thousands of personal
tragedies like Michelle's and Tony's and
they joined hundreds of victims hopeful
they will finally hear the truth about
the biggest treatment scandal in the
history of the NHS
[Music]
it began with the commemoration of the
dead and the dying a community finally
given voice for their grief and anger
with almost 5000 people infected and
nearly three thousand and Counting
killed the death toll from contaminated
blood Dwarfs that of every other British
public scandal of the last 50 years
combined until now it has never had a
focal point victims and their families
hope this inquiry will finally hold
those responsible to account chairman
Sir Brian Lang staff said the number of
victims could grow with thousands of
transfusion patients possibly unaware
they've been infected and he promised
the inquiry would investigate
allegations of a government cover-up
compelling witnesses to appear if
necessary it is willing to hold people
to account where appropriate and it will
express its views at the end without
fear or favour affection or ill-will at
the end of an emotional day his message
was welcome I'm very encouraged why I've
heard today I almost feel today that
he's given that twelve-year-old boy a
voice so yeah we we're over the moon we
just hope now that it is seen through to
the end and that we get the outcome that
the right outcome this inquiry will take
at least two years
but Michelle Tony and all those affected
may at last be at the beginning of the
end
Paul Kelso Sky News